North Korea's leader warns that all the  u.s. is within range of his nuclear  missiles in a New Year's Day address Kim  jong-un said quote a nuclear button is  always on my desk chip Reid is in West  Palm Beach Florida with President  Trump's reaction Jim good morning  well good morning when asked about Kim  jong-un's claim the president would only  say we'll see but he did weigh in on  another major international story the  protests in Iran have entered their  fifth day police are clashing with  demonstrators who are voicing their  frustrations with their government  president Trump tweeted the USA is  watching very closely for human rights  violations the president celebrated the  new year at his mar-a-lago estate with  family friends and cabinet members he'll  return to Washington this evening to  begin work on his 2018 agenda Tony thank  you very much